so babe it chassis my girl I thought I'd
take you on the perfect date tonight
Oh tango you are such a good boyfriend I
told my mom she was wrong about you
well it's not bringing mama but I'm will
take you out on the best date ever we're
gonna kill people we're gonna go on a
maybe a rollercoaster ride nyan I don't
know oh I'm so excited
Oh Tongo like what did you find Honda
this unlocked car how convenient
get in you bit don't you you're always
low oh he's so goddamn slow yep you do
too much crack all right let's go get
some guns Jesse I love you Tom done well
I don't I don't love you know I look at
hate you got him thrown in my ass but
you don't be mad at I'm [ __ ] you know
what I have a surprise for him
hey let's go in the car I'm sorry
you can't say you're sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry too baby
is it healthy relationship we're a
modern Bonnie and Clyde
I am the loaded one I'm I'm pulling all
the bread in this family but you don't
got any money
no you are
let me hook anymore I don't want no guy
touching my girl anymore Tonga
sweetheart I'm I'm a little bit light on
funds
would you mind find me a nice semi-auto
what happened to that first semi-auto I
gave you what you do with that you sold
it for crack I know you did just a
little crack well I've got my trusty
hammer I feel like that's that's all I
need that in my sweetheart I'm ready
let's go I'm gonna die
in the car yeah in the car now I'm
wearing the tube top over here
don't yell at me not the car god damn it
you think I don't know about Cindy [ __ ]
yeah she was nobody you're the one break
my heart I'll break your eyes she was
nobody thank you my ticket crazy yeah
that's it sweetheart
I'm sorry I am sorry I'm sorry
look you know you need we needed by the
shittiest place let's never fight again
let's never fight again you get on my
phone we're gonna buy a nice little
place that [ __ ] looks great
whatever you want here we go mama gets
what mama likes I'm thirsty let's buy
some beer and then we'll rob the store
good we're in a new town I've got a new
place doesn't we have to change who we
are I want to drink fancy things from
now on [ __ ] Tonga you are the worst
driver I know that's my nose look looks
like [ __ ] hi no look at me you're always
angry with me alright baby they'd find
you you know you're right oh maybe I
just need a fix that's what you want you
want your fix
who are you goddamn fix our then that's
what you have
alright here we go we're gonna go here
play it cool buy some stuff and then
we'll rob them let's play it cool but
you gotta wait
that makes no one Jass t put your
[ __ ] gun away got you
he'll know how cam already you have the
hammer ready ok alright
come I loud to have a hammer in the
stuff just have it ready have it written
all right hey oh yeah oh they just
opened this great news okay well we're
gonna take some Jessup play cool alright
I'm nervous oh good they have they have
oh he's live we gotta get to our place I
haven't spoken to the landlord yet but I
should be a promise Co did you give them
my references oh this is where we went
on our first date
that's right you had a whole crack where
after you sale you knew how to treat a
woman do it pulling drive forward oh
wait shut up I do that sweetheart you
want me to come on in the name it that's
just the name all right this is our eyes
it's everything I always wanted don't
you exaggerate wait till you see this
place it's amazing all right so I put
some crack in this bong we'll have some
of this you sure know how to treat a
girl oh you're really coughing uh
tripping yeah
stop looking so stupid those glasses
take all those glasses
I just need to get a little high first
oh yeah
I was always told your nose was a mite
old shut up when I'm wearing high heels
that's why I didn't know you were so
short shut up
I'm not these people come here my little
garden gnome Jessie I think we should go
kill some people I'm feeling it I love
how you do I think this
don't talk to that woman don't you talk
to that woman hey
Oh Jesse what the hell you will never
look at another woman all right fine
all right let's take this car this car
is nice where are we going
shut up Tommy you've never taken me out
on a date I'm going to fairgrounds and
that's it and then you shut up okay
should I wait yeah you I'll wait for you
right here
shut up yeah Oh your money okay I
figured something up let's go right what
did you get me you know we ran to the
cops you in the wrong way if you think
you're getting out of this date mister
you are Shh you are sorely mistaken
they're playing our song
oh they are let's go that fairground oh
yeah the noise I make when I'm happy you
you just don't hear it very often then
your mother
Oh the lives you like that oh the life
we're all running people over okay
oh there's a guy here this guy on the
ride uh should we oh we need to kill
them I get my hammer get your hammer out
baby uh you should see this I think you
think I think he's a little weird
well what's wrong is he's been oh sorry
oh wow I got for you baby
tango you're so impressive oh yeah
remember when I beat that guy up beam
that guy up hey sorry about that guy in
the moment oh I'm so excited
get down here you're gonna miss it I'm
sorry
$10 unbelievable Oh crack and see you
stupid-head you're blocking my view
chassis I love you raise your hands you
like this Babbitt I haven't been this
excited since we shot that man this is
the best date I've ever had that's great